do you remember the first meal you ever
made you must have been young yeah I
started cooking at eight I lived in a
pub restaurant um see you were set up to
be successful no but I was the FI kid at
school like you know but I like to earn
money so um Dad said like I'm not going
to give you money earn it so I used to
go in the kitchen prep peel you know
wash up yeah and and as school was going
like that at the weekends I was like
that so for me truly like cooking I feel
like saved saved I feel like music did
that for me I wasn't that kind of kid
either yeah everyone wants to be good at
something right so that first meal it
gives you that confidence that can carry
over yeah and I remember I did a full I
did a proper roast dinner with all the
trimmings potatoes gravy the sauces how
old were you 11 and and like everything
I hit it up a hot poket in the
microwave no I just remember my dad
saying well done son that was delicious
and I remember the hairs just go like
that was mine yeah but I just come out I
just come from a parents evening at
school which was which was really bad so
I'm like look what I can do yeah I think
that I think that's that's it yeah oh I
love that I think it's important for
kids to find something that they find
pride in themselves and they feel
confident in it carries over yeah it can
it can make like if you learn to I call
it like 10 recipes to save your life
right truly honestly if you I if I had a
wish it would be that every American kid
leaves at 16 knowing the 10 recipes to
save their life well they should teach
this in scho they have to it would save
the money whether they're rich or poor
they would eat deliciously there'd be
less people going to H most of stuff
going through hospital is Diet related
disease it's all good so it's like just
and that adventure of cooking like like
convenience and all that has has helped
us but not helped us so yeah so that's
what I feel my journey is doing these
books and and and the TV shows that we
do and I've been doing it a long time I
know I look young guys but um I I'm like
25 years in the business I'm I'm
literally like I've been around a long
time it's cool though that you're still
inspired with these new idea like you
had over 20 cookbook I've never dried up
thank the Lord oh I think when I get
bored I'll just quit but I can I can
just see things and I fantasize and I I
can fantasize about we're fantasize
about different things yeah I know know
but I fantasize about that as well you
know the two can come together beautiful
chocolate that might be my last book
there you go how to keep the fire
alive marriage five ways
with there's a lot of subliminal jok
happening here but I think America's
with us I like it I think you should
[Music]
be
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home